NIK SATHE: Good afternoon.
And for those of you watching
the Livestream, good day in
whatever time zone you're in.
My name is Nik Sathe.
I am part of the engineering
team for Google Wallet.
And over the last many, many
years, a decade or so, we here
at Google, along with many of
you, have been looking to
digitize the world around us.
We consume most media digitally,
whether it's
videos, books, music.
We communicate digitally.
We take digital pictures.
But the one thing in our lives
that has sort of resisted this
trend is our wallet, which has
remained strangely analog all
of these years.
Many of us have pieces of
leather or fabric stuffed full
of paper or plastic, that take
up our daily lives in such a
way that there are TV sitcom
episodes that are dedicated to
large wallets.
And there's also a medical
condition called fat wallet
syndrome that affects millions
out there in the world.
It seems like we destroy entire
rainforests to create
paper coupons.
But the redemption rate
is maybe 1% or 2%.
That's a pretty bad
ratio in my book.
And we also have a lot of
merchants, for people like me
that like to save money--
we want to sign up for
loyalty cards.
And the US households, on
average, have about 18 loyalty
programs that they've
signed up for.
But the majority of us leave our
loyalty cards at home and
don't actually benefit
from the savings
that we have out there.
So we have dead animals, dead
trees, and wallets full of
inanimate objects that don't
really help us do things, and
a shopping experience that's
actually still pretty arcane.
We still go to stores, look
for items, stand in line,
rummage around in our wallets to
find these coupons to save
some money, a loyalty card to
earn some points, and then
finally, a payment instrument
to make a payment with.
This is really not the way that
things should be working
in the digital era, is it?
And it's no wonder that
consumers have told us, and
probably told many of you as
well, that they really want
digital versions of offers
and loyalty cards, most
importantly.
And 53% of them have told
us that they want those.
But unfortunately, only
4% actually use them.
So why this disconnect?
What's up with that?
People want digital versions,
but they aren't
really using them.
One of the reasons may be that
in our efforts as an industry
to try to solve this problem for
consumers, we have created
literally hundreds of
applications that try to solve
this problem.
A simple search in any app store
will find over 1,000
apps for offers and 650
apps for loyalty.
But no consumer in their right
mind is going to want to have
more than a few of these
that they really want
to be engaged with.
Another issue that we've found
is that the very reason why
merchants want to engage in
these relationships with
consumers, to better understand
them so that they
can help them save time and
save money, is the data.
And unfortunately, because of
our arcane processes today,
many times the data that's in
loyalty programs is really
irrelevant.
We have many people that have
signed up as Elvis Presley,
which, by the way, is the most
common pseudonym used in
loyalty programs out there, or
Mickey Mouse or Donald Duck.
And I'm sure we have a few
Elvises in this room.
You don't have to admit it
if you don't want to.
So these are the sorts of
problems that we tried to set
ourselves up to solve
at Google.
And I believe that
we have made some
inroads in that effort.
So our vision is to create
a platform and enable an
ecosystem that will digitize
the entire wallet.
We want you to be able to take
digital versions of all sorts
of things that people carry
around with them today,
digitize them, move them up to
the cloud where they can be
used anytime, anywhere.
And as the lines blur between
physical retail of bricks and
mortar and online commerce,
we believe that this cloud
wallet, with digital content
combined with a mobile device,
will allow you to seamlessly
bridge from the online world
to the offline world.
So today, I'm very, very
proud to announce--
and excited to announce--
extensions of the Google Wallet
Platform, specifically
the Wallet Objects API.
And here to tell you a little
bit more about the details of
these capabilities
is Pali Bhat.
[APPLAUSE]
PALI BHAT: Thanks, Nik.
I'm very excited to talk to you
a little bit more about
the Google Wallet Objects API.
Because the first thing we did
with the Wallet Objects API
was make it extensible.
We wanted Wallet Objects API to
allow developers like you
to be able to store any type of
object into Google Wallet.
And this is not just limited
to the paper coupons or the
plastic loyalty cards that
Nik already talked about.
But this could be any object
that you can imagine.
So this could be key reports
that you want to store in, or
let your customers store.
It could be gift cards,
tickets, et cetera.
And of course, while we were
building out this extensible
platform, we wanted to change
these objects, these lifeless,
inanimate objects, into
rich objects that
you can engage with.
So we wanted you to be able to
engage with your customers
through sending them
personalized messages or
real-time updates.
And these real-time updates
could be point balances for
your loyalty card.
It could be expiring offers--
any sort of update that could
get you to engage with your
customers better.
And of course, we wanted to
facilitate all of this with
your brand within
Google Wallet.
So you get a complete branded
experience with your brand
that you can use to engage
with your customers.
And of course, like everything
else that you've heard about
today at Google, you get to
reach millions of Google users
by using the Wallet
Objects API.
But before we go too far into
the API, I just wanted to talk
a little bit about what the
customer experience, what the
user experience looks like, and
how that compares to the
world that Nik described
previously of what exists
today with paper coupons and
plastic loyalty cards.
So let's talk a little
bit about Maya.
This is your typical mom who's
very busy juggling multiple
jobs and also, doing most of the
shopping for her family.
And of course, in the current
world, when she needs to find
savings, or tries to save time,
what she has to do is
sign up for loyalty programs.
And these are usually cumbersome
paper forms or go
through a stack of paper coupons
where she finds offers
that are relevant to her.
And so we decided to make this
finding process, whether it's
loyalty cards, offers, or any
other objects that are of
interest to her, very,
very simple, either
within your own site--
and this is whether you're
a developer or merchant--
or within Google Wallet.
The next thing that she has to
do is go save this to Google.
Now, usually in the physical
world, what has to happen is
that you have to clip a paper
coupon or store a loyalty card
within your purse.
With Google Wallet objects
API, all you need is your
Google account.
So Maya can just use her Gmail
username and password and be
able to save any type
of wallet object to
Google for use later.
And of course, in a typical
shopping experience, Maya
would need to go in, find this
offer or loyalty card,
remember to use it.
And that remembering part
is really, really hard.
What we've heard is that a
majority of customers in the
United States today-- and Nik
referred to 18 loyalty
programs in the United
States today--
a majority of them, over half
of them, users like Maya
forget about.
So they sign up for it, then
just forget about it, and
leave it in a drawer.
And we are going to solve that
by giving you timely geo-fence
notifications at the right
time and place.
And it's going to work with
all of the other Google
technologies we have out there,
so that a user like
Maya always has these objects
showing up on their phone at
the right time and place.
And the use is, of course,
very simple.
Instead of digging through your
purse and handing it out
over checkout, you just have to
show your smartphone, and
it's there for use with a
barcode, or QR code, or
whatever other thing
you prefer.
And lastly, we don't want
that interaction
to stop right there.
We want you to be able to engage
with Maya and other
customers of yours through
the Wallet Objects API.
Now, what I wanted to do next
was talk to you about two of
the different types of objects
that we focused on.
And that includes loyalty.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit more about that.
And then David's going
to talk a little
bit more about offers.
Well, lots of merchants out
there have loyalty programs to
acquire and engage
their users.
And what all of them use to
acquire and engage their
users, there are many, many
problems with it.
And I'm going to talk about two
of the big problems that
exist with loyalty programs out
there today-- these paper
or plastic-based loyalty
programs-- and how we've
solved that with the Google
Wallet Objects API.
So the first, of course,
is sign up.
Today, the process for signing
up for a loyalty card happens
to be going and standing in
customer service, getting a
paper form, filling
it out, and then
handing it back to them.
Hopefully you get activated
immediately, or maybe it's a
few days later.
And then you have to fill out
all of the data that you have,
similar to your name,
et cetera.
And maybe you enter Elvis
Presley, maybe something else,
just because it's so cumbersome
to fill out.
And what we've done
is solved that by
introducing instant sign-up.
So what you can do now, as a
merchant or developer, is
allow your users to sign up
with just a few touches on
their phone.
And I'm even going to do a short
demo of that right now.
And the next thing, of course,
is real-time updates.
What you can do today is--
typically, most of these loyalty
programs do not even
have email addresses of
you, so they can't
communicate with you.
We'll enable real-time point
balance updates in
personalized messages.
And you'll see a little bit of
that in my demo as well.
And of course, we decided
to make this
really simple to integrate.
And it will work with your
existing loyalty programs.
So without further ado, I'm
going to switch to the
WolfVision here and show
you how this will work.
Now, one of the things I want
you to note is that this isn't
our consumer-facing
user experience.
This is just something that we
pulled together so that our
developers can see how
this would work.
So when we do the launch of
this Wallet Objects API
functionality, you will see
that some of this user
experience will differ.
But you can look at a first
screen that would just be an
introduction that tells me I
can store all of my loyalty
programs in Wallet.
So I'm just going to
get started here.
It shows me a list of all of the
amazing loyalty programs
that I could sign up for.
And we hope in partnership with
you that we'll have lots
of loyalty program you
can sign up for.
I think I'm going to
pick Marriott.
Because like lots of the folks
out here, we are staying at
the Marriott Marquis
that's close by.
And I'd love to have
some Marriott
Reward Points for that.
So the first thing it
will do is pull up
information about Marriott.
And it will tell me
a little bit more
about Marriott Rewards.
It tells me I can get
priority check-in.
That sounds pretty good
when I'm showing
up at 11:00 PM tonight.
And some free nights as well.
Turns out I'm not yet a member
of Marriott Rewards, so I'm
going to just say Join Now.
Well, it's already pre-populated
with my
information.
So you see my name.
And I'm just going to agree to
the terms of service, because
I trust Marriott.
And I'm going to create
my account.
And just like that, you should
see that my Marriott Rewards
Wallet Object should get
stored in my Wallet.
And I'm going to give
it a second here.
And look, nice.
I've joined the program, and my
account has been activated.
And this all happened
in real time.
And it's instant sign-up.
[APPLAUSE]
PALI BHAT: And you see, I
have my Wallet Object.
I've got my member ID.
And there's a message, even a
personalized message, from
Marriott Rewards for me.
And this Wallet Object can
be updated in real time.
So what this means for all your
developers out there is
that this is an opportunity
for you to create a Wallet
Object, and then engage with
your customers in real time.
So with that, what I'm going
to do is call over David to
talk a little bit more
about offers.
DAVID SINGLETON: Thanks, Pali.
My name's David Singleton, and
I'm Engineering Director for
Google Offers.
So even though I'm from the
Google Offers team, I'm here
today to tell you how anyone
can use the Wallet Objects
Save to Wallet API to save
offer objects from your
website directly to their
Google Wallet.
And Nik and Pali have already
explained a little bit about
how digital wallets can bring
paper coupons to life.
Not only is it much easier to
have and carry my phone with
me-- it's probably already in my
pocket compared to a stack
of paper coupons that I might
be interested in.
But a problem that I find
frequently with coupons is
that I always forget
to use them.
How many times have you pulled
a crumpled piece of paper out
of your wallet to discover
that the expiration
date was long past?
It's something that happens
to me all the time.
Once an offer is saved to Google
Wallet, the app will
actually keep track and remind
users when they're near a
store and they can actually
best redeem the offer.
And that way, they're much less
likely to go unredeemed.
So let's take a look
at how this works.
Pali already introduced you
to Maya, who is a mother.
She's got two children.
And this weekend, she would
like to buy some new
shoes for her kids.
So what she does-- she
likes to save money--
she goes to her favorite
couponing site on the web,
which is RetailMeNot.
And she's looking for an offer
that she could use close to
her home in Mountain View.
My RetailMeNot have integrated
the Wallet Objects Save to
Wallet API.
Let's take a look at
how that affects
Maya's experience here.
So she's scanning the
available offers.
And here's one that looks
interesting from Sports
Authority, 20% off one item.
We'll take a deeper look.
And what you can see here is
that there's a Save Offer to
Google button available
on the page.
Now, Maya's already signed in to
her Google account, so all
she has to do to save that
offer is a simple click.
And now you can see it says
that the offer is saved to
Maya's Google Wallet.
Let's take a look over here.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID SINGLETON: Thanks.
Let's take a look over
on her phone.
And you can see that the offer
is already available there.
And she could go directly into
the store to use it.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID SINGLETON: We switch back,
she can continue her
browsing experience.
Here's another one from Forever
21 that looks great.
Again, just a single
click to get that.
Now, let's fast forward
to Saturday morning.
Maya drives to the mall, pulls
into the parking lot, and
let's take a close look at what
happens on her phone.
So what you can see right here--
it just when buzz.
And there's actually a
notification already on her
phone reminding her that she has
a saved offer nearby that
she can use at Sports
Authority.
So she goes into the store.
She goes into the store, walks
around, finds the shoes that
she was looking for.
Maybe picks up a yoga
mat on the way out.
And all she needs to do now is
go back to that notification
on her phone, tap it, and she's
taken directly into the
redemption screen for
that saved offer.
In order to use it, all she
needs to do now is show it to
the cashier at the point
of sale, and she
saves her 20% off.
So with the Wallet Objects Save
to Wallet API, you can
take advantage of distribution
on your own website.
But alongside the Wallet Objects
Platform, we have
Google Offers, which allows
you to extend your reach
through Google properties across
the web, search ads on
Maps, which you might
have seen during the
keynote demo earlier.
You don't have to use Google
Offers in order to take
advantage of the Wallet
Objects Platform.
But using the Save to Wallet API
gives you a seamless path
for users and merchant staff, if
you do decide to upgrade to
Google Offers, to extend
that reach.
And now I'm going to hand
back to Pali to
explain a little more.
[APPLAUSE]
PALI BHAT: Thanks, David.
So we know that the world's
top developers join us at
Google I/O. And we're excited to
tell you that our platform,
the Wallet Objects Platform,
isn't limited to just loyalty
cards and offers.
So I want to show you two
examples of how we've created
an extensible platform for
you to take advantage of.
So the first thing that I want
to talk about is the types
that are supported within
Google Wallet.
What we've done is picked the
two most commonly used
examples, which is loyalty
cards and offers.
But you could actually go in and
save any type of object to
Google Wallet.
So these objects could be as
simple as a library card to
your local town's library.
Or, it could be as sophisticated
as the Wallet
Object that our partner
BillGuard has built, which
lets you get alerted for
fraudulent transactions on
your credit card.
And so really, the limit
here is only by
what you can imagine.
So I would encourage all of
you to partner with us to
create innovative
Wallet Objects.
And we will actually make an
effort, on specific types of
objects, to share it with
standards bodies, like
schema.org so that everyone
can take advantage of it.
The second thing that we've
done is we've created a
platform in which all of the
ecosystem providers out there
and developers out there can
build very, very interesting
tools on top of this platform.
So an example is Urban Airship,
which is one of our
partners, which is showcasing
their tool within a Sandbox at
Google I/O on the
second floor--
I hope you join us there.
And they've made a drag and drop
tool that will let you
create a Wallet Object.
And so this is an example of the
Urban Airship tool being
used to create Alaska Airlines
loyalty card.
If you want to learn more
about this tool and this
integration, I'd encourage you
to stop by at our Sandbox.
So we haven't stopped
right there.
We've got a number of different
partners that have
joined us today.
So it's Alaska Airlines,
Belly, BillGuard, BJ's
Restaurants, The Body Shop,
Marriott Rewards, Raley's, Red
Mango, and RetailMeNot.
And all of these brands are
already integrating into the
Wallet Objects Platform.
In addition, if you want to make
it much, much simpler to
integrate, then we've had a
bunch of tools partners and
technology providers, like
Accelitec, Blackhawk, Loyalty
Lab, Paytronix, ProfitPoint,
Urban Airship, and Vibes
already signed in, which
together, power over 300
loyalty programs, offers,
et cetera.
And so we'll make it really
simple for you to onboard, if
you want to participate in the
Wallet Objects Platform.
So I encourage you
all to do that.
And to wrap up, I'll hand
over to Nik Sathe.
NIK SATHE: Thanks, Pali.
I hope you guys have a bunch
of creative ideas that have
started to turn over in your
minds as we have been
imagining for the last few
months while we've been
working on this platform.
I did want to summarize a couple
of things, just to make
sure that we get the meat of
the content out there.
Whoops.
Guess I went too far.
So as you've heard from Pali and
David, the Wallet Objects
Platform is intended to be a
set of capabilities that
empower you, as developers and
innovators, whether you're
working for yourselves trying
to engage directly with
consumers or whether you're
working on behalf of retailers
and merchants out there
to help them
engage with their customers.
We believe we've given you a
rich set of functionality that
you can innovate on top of,
create branded experiences to
engage your customers, or engage
consumers out there.
And to make sure that you do
that with the distribution
that Google can provide you with
through the Google Wallet
application.
We already have millions of
Google Wallets out there, as
you've probably heard.
They're available on a growing
number of devices.
And our ambitions are to
significantly increase that
footprint later this year.
We've only touched on the
surface, and I want to make
sure that you have opportunities
to hear more.
Immediately after this, there
is a session down the hall
that's called Loyalty
Deep-dive.
It's not just about
loyalty programs.
They will talk more about the
data structures behind Wallet
Objects, the APIs, and the ways
that you can use that to
further your goals.
We also have a sign-up form
where we will start issuing
API credentials in the next
couple of days, after the buzz
around I/O dies down.
And you have a chance to go
to the Sandbox, as Pali
mentioned, to not just see the
Urban Airship tools that have
been built, but also other
capabilities from partners
such as ProfitPoint.
So I hope that this has
given you a sense for
what we have built.
The intention was to allow
you, as developers, to
innovate freely.
And also, gain the distribution
that's required
to reach millions of consumers
out there.
Without any further ado, let
me go ahead and call my
colleagues up for Q&A. If you
have a question, please come
down to the microphones so
that the folks on the
Livestream can hear you.
[APPLAUSE]
PALI BHAT: And just one--
can you turn my mic on?
Just one quick note to add,
speaking of freely.
This API is available free of
cost to all developers.
So please do take
advantage of it.
NIK SATHE: No questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NIK SATHE: There's got
to be the first one.
I think that'll loosen
the crowd up.
AUDIENCE: Owen Thomas
from ReadWrite.
When you talk about Google
Wallet being available on more
devices, I'm sure a lot of
developers are thinking this--
iOS?
NIK SATHE: So we can't
specifically
comment on future plans.
But as I said, even today we
have Google Wallet available
on millions of devices.
We are adding to those devices
daily, weekly, certifying new
devices and carriers.
And our ambitions and our
plans are to extend that
footprint significantly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NIK SATHE: Thank you.
PALI BHAT: Yeah, please come
to the microphones in the
center of the room.
You can just circle
around the front.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is Eduardo.
I'm from Brazil.
I saw some examples where you
use credit cards as the
payment method.
But in emerging markets like
Brazil, Argentina, Colombia,
Mexico, carrier [? billing ?]
is still very strong.
So I'm not sure if I lost
something in the presentation,
but do you have plans to go
to emerging markets in
partnership with carriers to use
carrier [? billing ?] in
the platform?
NIK SATHE: So what we talked
about just now had nothing to
do with payments, per se.
And it might be a more
appropriate question for you
to come to our booth and talk
about specifically with regard
to our payment plans, since this
was really more extending
the Wallet beyond payments into
the kinds of things that
consumers would want to engage
with on a daily basis.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Drew
[INAUDIBLE] from New Zealand.
There's plenty of offer
platforms out at the moment.
One of the things that doesn't
get catered for is the
redemption side on the
point of sale.
Is there any sort of support
beyond the Wallet that you're
giving to the retailers?
DAVID SINGLETON: So our vision
with the Save to Wallet API
for Offers is that retailers
can use their
own existing systems.
And they can use this platform
to take coupon data that they
might have already, get it
onto mobile devices.
But then, in store, the
experience can be consistent
with whatever they're
doing already.
So you saw, I think, the
redemption experience that we
showed here.
And that was very much in line
with what Sports Authority,
for instance, as an example,
are already doing.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, just to ask.
So one of the things might
be a one-time voucher.
What are you doing?
Have you got considerations
for that?
DAVID SINGLETON: So I'd really
encourage you to take a look
at the Wallet Object's
documentation.
One of the things that
you can do here is--
there are two concepts.
There's a concept of
a class of object.
So on offer with a certain set
of terms would be a class.
And then, when an offer is being
saved to Maya's account,
she was actually receiving
an instance of it.
The platform's very flexible and
extensible, so it would be
possible for the issuer to
actually generate unique
codes, for instance.
I really encourage you to take
a look at the documentation,
which is at this URL.
AUDIENCE: It was not found
when I had a look.
PALI BHAT: Yeah, just one other
quick thing, is that
there is a session where we're
going to deep-dive into what
the API looks like.
That will probably clarify
a lot of these questions.
And that's going to start
in the next 25 minutes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PALI BHAT: Yeah.
NIK SATHE: Thanks.
Go ahead, in the front
of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hi, John
from Chicago.
So the APIs are available now.
When is the Wallet app
going to be updated?
When can we expect to actually
get this into
the hands of consumers?
Thanks.
PALI BHAT: Yeah, so we expect
to have the Wallet app
available very soon,
as soon as we can.
But of course, we don't have
a specific timing to
announce right now.
But stay tuned to our blog.
NIK SATHE: I think the one thing
I would add is in order
for the app to be adopted
widely, we need
to have great content.
So I would encourage you guys to
start building the content,
and we will be releasing that.
Again, it's not our policy to
talk about specific dates in
the future.
But it will be as
soon as we can.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any sample
apps that are already
live on Google Wallet?
PALI BHAT: No.
So we haven't actually made any
sample apps available for
develops who don't
have API access.
But the best thing to do is just
sign up for API access.
And as soon as you see that,
you'll get a sample app in
your hands as well.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
The link doesn't seem to work.
NIK SATHE: I'm sorry.
What was that?
AUDIENCE: The link doesn't seem
to work on the sign-up
[INAUDIBLE].
PALI BHAT: Oh, the link
isn't working?
Yeah, we'll get that
fixed right away.
MALE SPEAKER: I'll get
the link fixed.
In the meantime, just go to
google.com/wallet/business,
and you can sign up there.
PALI BHAT: So for those who are
on Livestream, you said
google.com/wallet/business, and
you can sign up there if
this link doesn't work.
But the link will start
working soon as well.
NIK SATHE: Any other
questions?
Great.
One thing that we didn't talk
about is we started the
platform with loyalty
and offers.
We will be working with the
community to try to find the
next set of types that we will
add semantic definition to.
And we are working with
organizations, like
schema.org, to try to establish
semantic standards
that these things can have, so
that other types can have
interoperability in the
future as well.
So if any of you are interested
in helping us
define the next set of reified
types, as we call them, where
we can add more semantic
definition to the syntax that
the platform provides, we'd love
to hear from you in our
Sandbox as well.
PALI BHAT: OK.
NIK SATHE: OK.
PALI BHAT: Yeah, thank you.
NIK SATHE: Great.
Thank you very much.
DAVID SINGLETON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]